suis très heureux de voir ce soir
j'aurais préféré de te voir dans
d'autres conditions je sais je sais
était très très touché par la
disparition col bat
jeter en moto2 thaler et puis on est en
train de se préparer pour venir faire la
promo chez toi et gt gt avec la pac il
dit gg une mauvaise nouvelle et puis on
était sûr on était sur un contrat et je
fais pas le contrat zhao pas du tout et
il me dit bah jean paul est décédé
donc
voila quoi
je pense qu'il a été
si c'est bien tapé ouais c'est vrai et
puis ça fait drôle mais je pense qu'il
était au bout quoi je sais que tu avais
tourné avec lui en 2011 dont l'aîné des
ferchaux
c'était devenu un mec moi c'était un
remake
d'un vieux film avec charles vanel et
lui lui et on a refait un remake pour
tf1 et moi je reprenais le rôle de jean
paul et jean paul reprenait le rôle de
charles vanel et c'est un film qui a été
réalisé par bernard stora c'était deux
téléfilm pour tf1 et c'était merveilleux
hausse est barrée au venezuela barcelone
avec nachi
c'était juste exceptionnel et puis moi
j'étais je sortais de taxi et ben ça
m'est tombé dessus comme ça on a fait un
dîner à la closerie des lilas parce
qu'il aimait bien rencontrer et puis je
voulais me rencontrer bam bam on a mangé
et puis ça a tout de suite collé entre
vous ouais je sais qu'il ya un match de
boxe en plus vendredi l'ayatollah qui
tony hawk à qui tu vas combat que je
sais que jean paul serait venu avec moi
comme comme d'habitude avec ses potes on
dirait que là ça nous c'est un foot boxe
mais ouais bah ouais toujours même
maintenant ouais ouais il raté par un
convoi et puis surtout y est ils étaient
tellement moi j'ai que je me rappelle du
du juste comme ça pour l'anecdote quand
j'arrivais et puis il la première scène
qu'on a tourné on était en banlieue
parisienne et fallait qu'ils me crie
dessus et moi c'est mon rêve depuis
demande aux 5 c'est comme de niro c'est
comme ça c'est vrai à quoi ces gamins
c'est ventura est la première chaîne
bernard stora indie ont fait on commence
par cette scène ils devaient me crier
dessus donc tapé à l'ordinateur est bien
une et alors ils me renvoient et je le
connaissais pas juste un petit peu on
avait fait un dîner est à quai et stores
à la trappe et redescendre un tout petit
peu tu as vu parce que elle et c'était
puis après ça a roulé on a passé deux
mois ils adorent et rigoler un joli ils
adorent et se marier ils adorent et le
sport ils adorent et qui fait